[Music]
conan o'brien and his team coco has
nothing to hide and has led advancement
to their world via the web team coco now
running 24 7. get ready for the coco cam
coco cam coco cam coco cam a video
camera set up a stairwell streaming live
and it began yesterday there's a dancing
taco a dancing taco actually took
requests from the fans on the twitter dr
darkheart wants to see the running man
mr darkart here it is that'd be a good
halloween costume the camera is sitting
in a stairwell and the staff is
providing the entertainment as you can
see it featured the 80s aerobics gals
dogs or a guy in a dog's suit playing
poker a couple was eating dinner the
binge eating contest oh what's going on
oh it's the zombies the zombies are
attacking there's a little uh odd nude
painting there why conan o'brien is
playing punishment bingo what are you
doing what is that guy doing
do you see this role there's our people
in bear suits who are doing aerobics and
we're not quite sure
why they're doing it this morning what
is this i'll tell you what this is i
don't know but it's live
little bamba plug is a puzzle with
people here you can see george lopez uh
and some other people stealing stuff out
of conan's office
i think his dog the bounty hunter yeah
that's just
sandy richter all right so that's what
conan's doing in the meantime until uh
you know his show kicks off and lent her
all his race
with whom the father liking took two
hand puppets announced some of conan
o'brien's first guest on his new show
tom hanks seth rogen and soundgarden
will appear in the first week fans can
vote for who they want is conan's first
guest conan's show debuts on november
the 8th check it out